there's a second catalyst that happened
which was
right before my senior year of college
my dad died really suddenly
he had a heart attack while he was
playing tennis dead before he hit the
ground
and
we don't i mean anybody can imagine
that's [ __ ]
it was a week after my 21st birthday
like your whole life is gone
and he we were a close family he was
a huge part of my life and then i like
said goodnight to him one night thinking
i'd see him forever and he was just
[ __ ] gone and there was no rhyme or
reason there was no health issues he
never knew that he had any heart
complications nothing just gone
just gone
no and he was like 56.
holy [ __ ]
it was
so unbelievably traumatic
that even to this day as i approached 40
myself i am still unpacking it and how
how my life was
i um
how my life was
built around it the scar tissue of that
and so in that moment
instead of doing what i planned to do
which was moved to new york when i
graduated i finished my senior year and
i moved back to dc
and
my dad worked at the world bank that was
his job when he died
and the world bank
for some unknown reason to me offered me
an internship which is like the gold
ring of international finance
internships but i was a theater major
it doesn't make any sense
it didn't make any sense um
and i sat there for the summer and i
kind of
i just put my head shut and resume
into an envelope because i saw the
folger theater was casting
a show that needed girls in their 20s
and i started doing shakespeare in dc
and
i thought you know what this would be
great i'll be a shakespeare actor in dc
only getting money but like what how
nice
and then i got cast and play
and after the table read i was fired for
being back
for being bad oh i was bad at the table
reading they're like she can't do this
so they replaced me that was the first
time you ever were fired or let go of
something right how did that feel i was
rejected constantly i was not very good
for a long time really
yeah
i mean we all get better we all learn we
all like if you study and you do this
but do you think you had natural ability
or do you think that you just really had
to work hard to be as good as you are
um
i think i came into the game a solid b
a b
yeah a b what the hell's wrong with a b
yeah but a b is a guest star twice a
year on various shows right you're not
making a living at a b
if you want to be a series regular if
you want to be a part of the
conversation you've got to be this is
the [ __ ] olympics
you got to be an a i don't know i see a
lot of b minuses c pluses c minuses i'll
go even to d's on some tv there's a lot
of tv there's a lot of great tv there's
also a lot of bad tv and there are a lot
of grades maybe the grades are i don't
know what i'm saying is a b is pretty
good and you could be a working actor
with a b so you were you were good you
weren't bad but you had a lot to do you
had a lot more to learn
right
yeah so i got fired and because of this
traumatic event like my dad's this is
like a year we're still within the year
or two after he died i thought to myself
if this world is gonna [ __ ] on me
i'm not getting [ __ ] on
in washington [ __ ] dc
i'm gonna get [ __ ] on in new york or la
i flipped a coin
just like that